Emotional intelligence, also known as EI or
EQ, is the brain's ability to see feelings
coming — and then to use them, listen to what
they’ve got to say, and manage them effectively.
People with lots of EI recognize their own
emotions and can identify them in others. This
allows them to discern between different feelings,
adjust their inner states and communicate better.
Perhaps the most relevant model
of “emotional intelligence” was
developed by the psychologists John Mayer and
Peter Salovey, who defined it in 1990 as the
sum of four skills: perceiving, using,
understanding, and managing emotions.
Perceiving Emotions is our ability
to detect them in faces, pictures,
and voices — including in ourselves. It’s
the foundation of emotional intelligence
and makes all other processing of
sentimental information possible.
Using emotions is the ability to align
our hearts with our heads. People who
are emotionally intelligent can perceive
their changing moods and as a result,
may change what they do to channel
their feelings effectively.
Understanding emotions is our ability
to comprehend the complex relationships
between feelings. It involves recognizing and
describing how moods evolve and change over time.
Managing emotions is the ability to
regulate feelings in ourselves and
in others. People who are good at
that can control their sentiments,
manage their moods, and are able to
influence the emotions of others.
While some people seem to be naturally gifted with
all four abilities, others have to work hard on
every single one of them. The good news is, most
of us can improve our EI through mindfulness,
exercises, therapy, and education.
And it seems it’s worth the effort!
Higher emotional intelligence often
correlates with higher academic and
professional success. This is
because our emotions and the way
we manage them impact directly on our
brain’s ability to listen and learn.
As Peter Salovey concluded: “People in good moods
are better at inductive reasoning
and creative problem-solving.”
So what do you think? Is emotional intelligence
something we can and should try
to teach in schools? And if so,
how? Tell us your thoughts and experiences of
improving your own EI in the comments below.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com